NICOLAS GEOFFRAY: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for
coming to this talk.
You'll hear about ART,
the Android Runtime.
And all about the
new, exciting features
we've worked on
for Android N. I'm
Nicolas Geoffray, a software
engineer in the ART team,
and I'll be presenting
along my colleagues
Mathieu Chartier
and Calin Juravle.
So ART is the software
layer between the operating
system and the applications.
It provides an
execution environment
to run Android applications.
That environment essentially
consists of two things.
It is a huge text bytecode,
that's the internal Android
format and Android applications,
through a mix of interpretation
and computation.
It also manages memory
of those applications,
allocating it and reclaiming
it when it's no longer used.
Why should you guys
care about ART?
Well, it turns out ART is
at the forefront of the user
experience.
ART needs to be fast so that
applications can run smoothly.
It needs to start
applications really quickly
to give a snappy
experience to the user.
It needs to ensure
the UI can render
at least 60 frames per second
to make the user experience
jank free.
It needs to be
power-efficient and not
do too much extra work besides
executing the application.
And it needs to be savvy
in terms of memory use.
The less memory being used
by the Runtime, the more
applications you
can actually run.
So if you remember Dalvik,
which was the first Android
Runtime released
in Android phones,
it was sort of efficient
on some of these metrics,
and sort of OK on a few.
At the time memory
footprint was paramount,
so we constrained the compiler
to not use much memory,
and that explains
not-so-great performance.
Dalvik also had a relatively
unsophisticated garbage
collector, and that could lead
to long application pauses,
leading to a janky experience.
So in 2014 we introduced ART.
ART shifted the paradigm
of doing interpretation
and Just-In-Time
computation at runtime
to a Ahead-Of-Time computation
when the application is
being installed.
So when the application
is being installed,
ART will compile it
directly to optimize code.
That gave us a great boost on
performance and application
startup.
ART did not need a
Just-In-Time compiler
to be warmed up before
it could execute.
Applications were running out
of optimized code directly.
And because this code is
directly loaded from disk,
you don't need to pay the
cost of a JIT computation code
cache.
The garbage collector has
also been completely revamped,
where we implemented a
state-of-the-art concurrent
garbage collector algorithms,
and we made sure that GC pauses
were to a minimal so that
the experience was jank free.
Since Lollipop we've mostly
improved on performance,
so we have [? evolution ?]
right on the compiler.
Lollipop, when we
shipped, had a quick--
when we shipped Lollipop
it had a quick compiler.
That was a fast dex thanks
to machine code compiler.
It was ported from the
Davik JIT at the time.
At the time we were
really eager to ship
ART, given all the
benefits, and we mostly
focused on shipping a
well-tested and robust
compiler.
However, [? Quick ?]
was not structurally
meant for more sophisticated
optimizations, such as inlining
and register allocation.
So in Marshmallow we introduced
the optimizing compiler.
That's a state-of-the-art
SSA-form-based compiler
infrastructure.
SSA, in compiler jargon, stands
for Static Single Assignment.
And that's a well-known
format for doing optimizations
in the compiler.
We implement all sorts of
optimizations such as inlining,
[? bomcheck ?]
emulation, command
super-expression
emulation, and so on.
We also implemented a leaner
scan register allocator,
a state-of-the-art register
allocation technique
for compilers.
And in N we iterated
on the compiler
and made more aggressive
optimizations,
like more inlining and
lots more optimization.
This graph shows the
performance of Marshmallow
and [INAUDIBLE] normalized
for performance in Lollipop.
[? As ?] benchmarks
run on Nexus 9,
a tablet where we
[? should ?] Lollipop,
and the first
[? will leaves ?] of ART.
And you can see we've
constantly improving performance
over time.
We measured on three
different kinds of benchmarks.
Delta [? and ?] Richards are
well-known object-oriented
benchmarks in the [? Android ?]
[? community ?] that stresses
how the runtime implements
[? calls. ?] Dhrystone is about
how the runtime in the compiler
generates integer computations.
Reversibench,
Chessbench, and Ritz
are actually adaptations
of Android applications.
Reversi and Chess emulate
the AI of an actual game
that you can download
from the Play Store
and reads emulate
spreadsheet emulation.
So we've been very pleased with
the improvements we've made
here, ranging from
1.2x to 5x speed-ups.
And the performance boost isn't
specific to one architecture.
Because most of
our optimizations
are CPU independent, all
platforms benefit from them.
So running the same
benchmarks on ARM32
will lead to the
same improvement
trend across the board.
So that's great.
Improving the code
generated by the compiler
is a great win for performance,
faster frame rendering,
and faster start up.
Great, but--
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLES]
It looks like you
guys run into this.
So you're probably familiar
with that dialogue now.
It's pretty lucky, right?
Only 21 to go.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
So that dialogue
is what is shown
when you take a system update.
And what happens there,
in case you don't know,
is that we are redoing
all the optimizations
we've done at install
time of an application.
Why?
Because when you
install an application,
ART will optimize it heavily
against your platform.
And it will put
hard-coded dependencies
in the compiled code that will
make your application run much
faster.
But when you get a
system update all
those hard-coded
dependencies become invalid
because you've got a new system.
So we need to redo all the work.
When we shipped ART, that
was actually a trade-off
we've made because OTAs or
system updates were usually
once a year.
So for a once a year
updates you get yearly
better Android experience.
But Android ecosystem
has evolved.
And security being at the heart
of Android, our security team
worked hard on
making sure security
fixes could be sent to Android
phones as soon as possible.
So when our Lead Security
Engineer and Director
of Nexus Products
announced we are now
moving to monthly updates,
it was sort of clear
that this initial trade-off
we've made would not work
and ART needed to adapt.
So we brought back a
Just-In-Time compiler in ART.
So no more "optimizing
app" dialogue.
Woo-hoo!
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It turns out, removing
that dialogue is not
the only benefit
of having a JIT.
We now get much faster
installs, around 75% faster.
And because AOT could not
know, when it was compiling,
which parts of the
app is being executed,
it turns out that
we were compiling
all the code of your APK.
And that is sort of a
waste of your storage
if you're going to use
just 5% or 10% of the code.
But I think a JIT
has some unknown.
[? That ?] clearly keeping
on compiling all the time,
like you started your app
with JIT, you kill the app,
you start it up again, your JIT.
It has some implications
on your battery,
that AOT compile
code didn't have.
And having a
compilation code cache
could be wasteful if
not managed properly.
So what we did in N is
introduce a hybrid Just-In-Time
[? half-time ?] compilation
system that combines
the benefits of both worlds.
The idea is that, applications
start running with a JIT,
and when the phone is idle
and charging ART will do
profile-guided optimizations.
And Ahead-Of-Time
heavily optimized
the parts of the application
that JIT has executed already.
So later in this talk, my
colleague Calin will go
into more detail about how
this hybrid AOT JIT profile
[? GAD ?] [? and ?]
compilation works.
What I want to focus now
is, how is the [? unknown ?]
with the JIT?
Let's go back to
the five metrics
I mentioned earlier in the talk.
For runtime
performance the JIT is
based on the same AOT
compiler that brings
the same high performance.
So we're covered.
But the other metrics
are actually down
to how we tune the JIT.
A couple of things
we made when starting
this project, a couple of
design decisions we made,
were based on those metrics.
Like, we implemented a much
faster interpreter in N
compared to the
one in Marshmallow.
It runs, like, up to 3x
faster than the [? App ?]
[? startup ?] in Marshmallow.
It's very important to
have a fast interpreter
because when you
start your app you
don't have any
Ahead-Of-Time compiled
code its [? gentura ?] is going
to run, and later on the JIT.
Second, [? we do ?]
a JIT compilation
on a separate thread and not
on the application threads,
some compilation
can take very long,
and you don't want to
block the UI thread just
for doing compilation.
For saving power
what we do is mostly
focusing on the hottest
methods of an application.
And finally, for
memory footprint,
we implemented a garbage
collection technique
that ensures that only the
methods that in the end
matter, over time, are kept.
So if a method is being
compiled and then not
being used anymore, we'll
remove it from memory.
All right.
So let's focus on
application startup.
Now I'm going to walk you
through some Sys Trace that
will explain some of the
implementation decisions
we're made.
If you don't know
what Sys Trace is,
it's a great tool for both
app developers and platform
developers to analyze what is
happening on Android system.
So bear with me.
There's a lot of
information on that slide,
but we'll focus on the
things that matter for us.
So here's how Sys Trace
looks after launching
Gmail on a device that had
Gmail Ahead-Of-Time compiled.
So application
startup for a user
is actually when the first
frame is being rendered.
And this trace here is
[? somewhat, ?] more or less,
what you would get on
Marshmallow and Lollipop,
is that for starting
Gmail, it would
take half a second for the
first frame to be drawn.
So our first implementation
or alpha implementation
of the JIT, we did
the same measurements.
And results were not great.
You can see now the startup
is around one second,
so we increased the
startup around 2x.
And you can see that the
JIT thread here executing
is initially idle, and
then becomes very busy.
So what's happening?
If you take a closer look at
what the application is doing,
there's around 200 milliseconds
for doing just the APK
extraction.
And doing APK extraction
is blocking the operation,
so you need to do it
before executing any code.
Similarly, there's lots of
things happening after the APK
extraction that don't have to do
with executing the application.
And that's verification.
ART needs to verify
the Dex code in order
to run it and optimize it.
So we fixed this problem.
We decided to move extraction
and verification out
of every application
startup and move it
back to when the application
is actually being installed.
So I just made the
application startup
two times faster than our
initial JIT implementation,
and quite on par
with compile code.
So I've just talked about
application startup.
How about jank?
For jank we looked
at the frame rate
of scrolling within the
Google Photos application.
And Sys Trace gives
you this nice ist
of frames that are being drawn.
A green frame is when the UI
managed to render it in time.
Orange and red is where
you're dropping the frame
and it hasn't been rendered.
Now jank can be attributed
to many factors.
And ART does its
best at executing
the code of the application.
But if the application does
too much on the thread,
obviously we're going
to miss a frame.
So we have-- for that specific
experiment, we have around 4%
of frames that
are being dropped.
During our first [? bring ?]
[? up ?] we made the same
experiment.
So application wasn't compiled,
it we'd just run it with a JIT.
And the results weren't great.
We were dropping
around 20% of frames.
If you take a closer look
at what the JIT is actually
doing here, you can see those
long compilation activities
where the compiler
is actually waiting
for methods or for requests
to compile methods.
Those methods haven't
reached the hotness threshold
that we've set.
And the hotness
threshold is high
because we want to
save on battery.
But that doesn't
save on saving jank.
The UI thread--
you want the code
that that thread is executing
to be hot as soon as possible.
So the solution was to increase
the weight of UI thread
requests for compilation.
So the methods it runs would
be compiled almost instantly.
So if you see
[? it's ?] [? trace ?],
there's no more long pauses
of compilations and we only
dropped around 4% of frames,
which was the OT level we had
initially.
All right.
Battery usage.
We've measured the power
usage of starting Gmail,
pausing for 30 seconds, and
then scroll around the emails.
And we can see here
that the JIT is
paying a high cost at
application startup
compared to Ahead-Of-Time
compilation.
But once startup is
done, the scrolling
actually has no difference
between AOT and JIT.
The reason for this difference
is that, as they start up,
the JIT is very busy
compiling a lot of methods.
And Gmail seems to be very
aggressive in executing code
at Startup, which
is not necessarily
the behavior of all apps.
So we've done the same
experiment with the other apps.
We've looked at Chrome,
Camera, and Photos.
Chrome and Camera are
mostly based on native code.
So here JIT doesn't
really-- is not
really useful for all
the things we mentioned.
And the power usage
is very similar
whether you're in AOT
setup or at JIT setup.
Photos, on the other
hand, does have Java code,
but doesn't have the
behavior that Gmail had.
And you can see that the
difference is, again,
very little.
That was battery.
Let's discuss about the final
metric, memory footprint.
So we looked at the overall
usage of our beta testers
within Google, and we
were quite happy to find
that the memory use of the
JIT is fairly reasonable.
The maximum we've seen on a
heavily-loaded system that
had lots of application
being executed
was around 30
megabyte, system-wide.
But on average
what we've seen is
that, in general, 10 megabyte.
For individual applications,
big Java applications
will take some memory,
like, four megabyte.
But on average,
most applications
have a reasonable
Java code size,
and the code cache is fairly
small, around 300 kilobytes.
So to wrap up on how JIT
affects these metrics when it's
being executed, we've seen
that performance in jank
are on par with the quality
level we had with ART
Ahead-Of-Time compilation.
And I have shown
you that it does
have a relative impact on
application startup, battery,
and memory footprint.
So now I'll be handing it
over to my colleague Calin,
and he's going to explain to you
how we're recovering from those
small regressions
compared to AOT by doing
[? Ahead-Of-Time ?]
profile-guided compilation.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
CALIN JURAVLE:
Thank you, Nicolas.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Calin and I'm
here today to give you
more details on
profile-guided compilation.
And this is a new
compilation strategy
that we introduced in N.
And, as my colleague Nicolas
mentioned, is a
combination between JIT
and Ahead-Of-Time compilation.
And it's mainly based
on the observation
that the percentage of
the application's code,
which is actually
worth optimizing,
is very small in practice.
And focusing on the
most important part
of the application
drives a lot of benefits
for the overall system
performance, and not
only limited to
recovering the slightly
regression that we have to
[INAUDIBLE] with this system.
So the goal here was to have
a full five-star system.
And this is what profile-guided
compilations help us achieve.
So let's take a look
a bit on the idea.
In a nutshell, we want to
combine execution profiles
before Ahead-Of-Time
compilation,
and that will lead to a
profile-guided compilation.
What it means is that,
during application execution
we'll record profile information
about how the app is executed,
and you will use
that information
to drive off-line optimizations,
but at a time when
the device is charging and
idling so that it doesn't take
resources out of our users.
So let's take a look into
more details how this works,
how it affects the lifecycle
of the application,
and how it fits together
in the JIT system
that my colleague talked about.
The first time the
application is executed,
the runtime will interpret it.
The JIT system will kick in
and optimize the hot methods,
and eventually this
cycle will repeat.
[? Imperil ?] with
the interpretation
and with the JIT
compilation will
record the profile information.
And this profile information
gets dumped to disk
at regular interval of times.
The next time that you execute
the app, the same process
starts again.
And the profile
files will eventually
be expanded with
new use cases based
on how the user used the app.
At a later point, when the
device is not in use anymore,
it's idling and charging,
and it's a state
that we call "maintenance mode."
We kick in the service.
And what the service
does, it takes
a look at the application,
it looks at the profiles,
and it tries to optimize the
application based on its use.
The output of the service is
actually a compiled binary,
and this compiled binary will
replace the initial application
in the system.
So now the next
time the application
is launched after this
service was executed,
the application will
contain different codes,
different states
of the same code.
So you may have code
which is interpreted
and eventually be
JIT-ed, and it'll also
have code which
Ahead-Of-Time compiled.
If the user, for example, uses
a new part of the application
that hasn't been
explored before,
that part will be
interpreted in JIT
and it will generate a
new profile information.
And so the cycle begins again.
So what's important
here is, we'll
improve the
application performance
as the user executes
it with new use cases.
And it will keep
recompiling it until we
discover all possible cases.
So let's focus a bit on
the profile collection
and how that impacts
the application
performance and other factors.
As I mentioned,
we do collect them
in parallel with the
application execution,
and what it focused
on is to make sure
that it has a minimal
impact on the performance.
And one factor that we put
a lot of attention into
is to have an efficient
caching and [? IO ?]
foretelling so that we minimize
the write operation to disk.
We also have a very
small file footprint,
and the amount of data
that we write to disk
is actually very, very small.
Another point, which
I mentioned before,
is that we keep expanding these
profiles as the app executes.
And, obviously, it depends
on the application,
it depends on the use case.
Our test shows that the
largest part of the data
is actually captured
during the first run.
Subsequent runs add to
the profile information.
It obviously depends how
the user used the app,
but the largest chunk
of the information
is actually captured
during the first execution
and that gives us
important data to work on.
A final point which is
worth mentioning here
is that, all the application
and all the users
get their own profiles.
And with that in mind, let's
take a look on what exactly
we record in this
profile information.
The first things
are the hot methods.
And what constitutes
a hot method?
It's a metric which you have
internal to your runtime,
and the factors that
contribute to it
are, for example,
number of invocations,
whether or not that method
is executed on the UI thread
so that you can speed
up requests that
will impact the users directly.
We'll use this information to
drive off-line optimizations
and to dedicate more time
to optimize those methods.
The second data that we
record are the classes
which impact the startup times.
How do we know they do so?
It means that they are loaded
in the first few seconds
after the user launched the tab.
And my colleague Mathieu
will go into more details
on how we use that to improve
startup times even more.
A final piece of
information that we record
is whether or not the
application code is loaded
in some other apps, and
that's very important
to know because it means
that the application behaves
more like a shared library.
And when it does so we'll
use a different compilation
strategy to optimize it.
So let's focus now
on the compilation
daemon, on the service that
actually does the compilation,
and let's take a look on
what [? decision ?] makes.
This is a service which
is started at boot time
by the system and is
scheduled for daily run.
Its main job is to iterate
through all the APKs installed
in the system and figure
out whether or not
we need to compile them.
And if we do need to compile
them, what sort of strategy
we should use.
The service wakes up
when the device becomes
idle in charging, and
the main reason for that
is that we don't want
to use user time when
the device is
active, and we don't
want to waste battery time.
So we delayed this until the
device is not in use anymore.
When the daemon wakes
up what it does,
it iterates with
the applications.
And the first questions
it asks is whether or not
the application code has
been used by some other apps
that they thought
that I was telling you
that we record in the profile.
If that's the case, then they
perform a full compilation
to make sure that all the users
benefit of the optimized code.
If it's not-- and this is the
case probably for the largest
percentage of the app.
It's a regular app, you don't
get used by some other apps.
We go into and perform
a much deeper analysis
on the profile information.
If we have enough new data, if
we collected enough information
about the application, then
we will profile a guide
compile that application.
We'll take a look
at the profiles
and then optimize
only the methods that
were executed so that we focus
on what actually the user used
from that application.
If, by any chance, we don't
have enough information-- let's
say we only know--
we only have data
about one single
method from the top,
then we'll just keep it
because probably it's
not worth optimizing.
And an important
thing here is that we
do perform the profile
analysis every time
that we run the daemon.
And that what that means
is that we might end up
recompiling the app again and
again until we no longer have
any new information about it.
And here you can
see that actually I
was talking about
different use cases
and how we apply different
compilation strategies.
Shared libraries get
a full compilation,
whereas regular apps prefer
a profile-guided compilation.
In N we generalized on that.
And different use cases from
the lifecycle of the application
have different
completion strategies.
For example, at install time we
don't have profile information,
yet we still want
the application
to start as fast as possible.
And as my colleague
Nicolas mentioned,
we have a strategy where
we extract and verify
that app with
minimal running time,
and which will ensure that
the application starts fast.
When you update the app
we have the same story.
We no longer have a
profile because what
it recorded before was invalid.
So we repeat this
[? education ?] procedure.
When the compilation
daemon kicks in,
we'll do a profile-guided
compilation where possible.
And for system and
shared libraries
we're going to do
a full compilation
so that we make sure that
all their users are properly
optimized.
With that in mind, let's
take a more closer look
on what benefits are when we
do profile-guided compilation.
And all the benefits
share the same root cause.
We only optimize
what is being used.
And what it means?
When you first start the app
after the compilation happened,
previous hot code is
already optimized.
We no longer have to wait
for the JIT, for the methods
to become hot so that
the JIT can compile them.
So the applications
will start faster.
We have also less
work for the JIT.
And that means we use less CPU
and we increase the battery
life overall.
And because we are
much more selective
with what we optimize, we can
dedicate and spend more time
there and apply
more optimizations.
Besides that we get a smaller
size for the compiled binary.
And that's a very
important thing
because what we do it as
binary [? map ?] into memory.
Smaller size translates to
reduced memory footprint,
and the important
difference here
is that, for example,
this memory that we
map into-- this binary
that we map into memory
will be a clean memory
compared to dirty memory
that JIT will generate.
We also use far less disk
space because the binaries
are much smaller
now and they free
a lot of space for our users.
How much space?
Let's take a look
at the numbers.
In this chart we compare
different applications,
which is Google Plus,
Play Music, and Hangouts.
And we tracked how the generated
binary for the compiled code
performance across
Marshmallow, which
is the blue line, N preview
during the first boot
which is equivalent of a fresh
install of the application,
which is the orange line.
And the green line
is how much it
takes for the
profile-guided compilation.
As you can see, the
reduction is more than 50%.
And obviously, the green
line will go up over time.
And our tests show that it
actually stays around 50%
most of the times.
And you may wonder, how come
we get so great reduction
in terms of size?
Well, when we
analyze the profiles,
we've realized that only
around 4% to 5% of the methods
actually get compiled.
And as we use the app more,
obviously this percentage will
go up, will generate more code.
But, as I said, in
general we stay below 50%,
or around that area.
Now a natural question
here is, if I'm only
compiling 5% of the app, how
come I reduce the space only
by 50%?
Why not 95?
Well, those lines contains also
the application [INAUDIBLE]
code, that Dex code.
And that's a line below
which we cannot go,
because we need
to run something.
And here is how we compare
to the application size.
You can see that,
in Marshmallow,
we generated more than
3x in terms of code size,
whereas in M we
stayed below 1.5x.
And these are all cool benefits,
but it is not the only thing,
actually, that we
use profiles for.
We also use them to farther
speed up system updates.
As my colleague
Nicolas mentioned,
because of JIT, we don't need
to recompile the app again.
And that basically gets
rid of the long waiting
time for the optimizing app.
We still want to do some
processing of the app,
in particular extraction
and verification,
to ensure that those apps get
executed as fast as possible
when they are first launched.
And in M we actually
know how those apps
were executed before.
So we can use profile to
guide the verification.
And that saves around
40% of the time extra.
We also added new,
improved usage stats.
And compared to M,
we can now track
precisely how the
application was used
and how it was executed.
And we only analyze what
actually matters for the users.
What is that?
Application [? has ?] a user
interface, and the users
can interact with them.
Those are the most
valuable for our users
and we focus on them
during system updates.
However, when we take the
update first update to M,
we don't have access
to all the goodies.
We don't have
profiles and we don't
have enough accurate
user stats to realize
how the app was used.
And what we do, we do
a full verification
of most of the apps.
This is still much, much
faster than we used to do in M.
And how much faster?
Let's take a look
at the numbers.
You can see here
three different lines.
And these numbers are
obtained on the same device
which have roughly 100
applications installed.
And the first line,
which represents
an OTA-- a system update
from M to M prime,
where we took a
security update--
we took around 14 minutes to
process all the applications.
And there's the time that the
runtime spends processing them.
When you take the update
to M, we reduce the time
to about three minutes,
which is up to 5x reduction.
And there we verify most
of the applications.
Now, the next step
our security updates
will kick in for
M. And what we do,
we already have
profile information,
improved usage stats,
and we can use that to
drive that time even lower.
And when you take a security
update on this device,
we take less than a minute.
And compared to M, that's
more than 12x improvement
in terms of speed up.
With that I'd like to
pass it to Mathieu,
and he will explain how we
use profiles to speed up
application even more.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
MATHIEU CHARTIER:
Thank you, Calin.
One new feature in N that
reduces application launch time
is application images.
An application image is
a serialized [? seed ?]
consisting of
pre-initialized classes.
This image is loaded by the
application during the launch.
During launch most
applications end up
loading many classes
for initialization work,
such as creating views
or inflating layouts.
Unfortunately, loading
classes is not free
and can consist of a large
portion of the application
launch time.
The way that application
images reduces this cost
is by effectively shifting work
from application launch time
to compile time.
Since the classes inside
of the application image
are pre-initialized,
this means they're
able to be accessed right off
the bat by the application.
Application images are
generated during the background
compilation phase.
I think it was Calin who
referred to it as a maintenance
phase, by the OT compiler.
Leveraging the JIT profiles,
the application images
include and serialize
only the set
of classes that were used
during prior launches
of the application.
Using the profile is also key
to having a small application
image, since it only includes
a small fraction of the classes
inside the actual application.
Having a small application
image is important
because the application
image is resident
in RAM for the entire
lifetime of the application,
as well as larger images
take longer to load.
As you can see here,
application images
have a very low
storage requirement.
This is mostly due
to the profile.
For the four apps here
the storage requirements
were less than two
megabytes per app.
As a comparison, I
put the application
that I compiled the application
code with the profile.
So this is already
reduced compared
to what application code
sizes would have been on M.
The loading process
of application images
begins with the application
[? ClassLoader ?] creation.
When the application
ClassLoader is created,
we load the application
image from storage
and decompress it into RAM.
For dynamically
loaded Dex files,
we also verified
that the ClassLoader
is a supported type.
Since there is no dependency
from the application compiled
code to the image, it means
that we can reject the image.
So if the ClassLoader
is not supported,
I simply reject the image
and resume execution.
Here are some results
for application image
launch time improvements
for the four apps
that I just displayed.
As you can see here,
there's around a 5% to 20%
improvement compared to
profile-guided compilation
only.
And now to the
garbage collector.
The garbage collector
has not changed too much
since our last IO presentation.
As you can see here we are
already in pretty good shape
back then.
There is still only
one short GC pause
and the garbage collector
has high throughput
since it is generational.
There have been a few GC
changes, mostly related
to application images
and Class Unloading,
however these
changes do not have--
or, these GC changes do not
have a substantial performance
impact.
One thing that has improved
each release is allocation time.
With L we introduced a new,
custom thread local allocator
that reduced allocation
time substantially
by avoiding
synchronization costs.
In N we removed all of the
[? comparance ?] [? womp ?]
operations in the
allocation common case.
Finally, in N, the allocation
common case has a [? written ?]
and [? hand-optimize ?]
assembly code.
This is the largest speed
up yet, at over 200%
compared to M.
Combined, all of
these improvements
mean that allocations are now
around 10x faster than KitKat,
which was Dalvik.
Class Unloading,
also introduced in N,
is a way to reduce RAM
for modular applications.
Basically, what this means is
that classes and class loaders
can be freed by the GC when
they're no longer used.
In previous Android
versions, these
were held live for the entire
lifetime of the application.
For classloading to
occur, all the classes
in the ClassLoader
most no longer
be reachable, as well as
the ClassLoader itself.
When the GC notices this
it frees them, as well as
the associated metadata.
This chart
demonstrates just a bit
of how the ClassLoader
interacts with other components
and retains them.
With that, off to
Nicolas for the wrap-up.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
NICOLAS GEOFFRAY:
Thank you, Matthew.
All right.
So to wrap up, we've
shown you all the features
we've worked on for N, mainly
a faster compiler, up to 5x
compared to previous releases.
A faster interpreter,
up to 3x compared
to Marshmallow, a
new JIT compiler
and profile-guided compilation.
They have just removed that
optimizing apps dialogue
and provides faster installs.
Applications image for fast
startup, and fast applications.
You can actually, if you're
interested in all that sort
of low-level stuff, follow
it on the AOSP website,
where we actually
do all development.
With that, we'll
take your questions.
Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]